mais pourquoi avons-nous demandé à ton père de
fais ça parce que dans la grand-mère tu touches
quand c'est une telle chose c'est
une infamie une trahison
c'est au plus proche parent de le laver
comment savoir si l'un des nôtres triche
Je vais le tuer moi-même, je suis le seul
pain avec cavalier le même que le sien
fils
un repenti est connu pour les demander
me rendant très à la maison même si c'est
ré-exploser poulain peut essayer
faire en sorte que ça devienne un accident comme la libye
nous serons sortis du jeune péché
nous avons vu que l'histoire nous apprend
qui peut aussi nous tuer au milieu
à la rue
ce n'est pas facile de survivre tu ne penses pas
Je suis en vie parce qu'ils ne veulent pas de moi
tue bobo et nous sommes avec toi mais ne sois pas
patron de la ndrangheta et de la mafia nocchia
linge possibilité travaux si toge commence
un crime en mode automatique fixe quelques un
total des cas le noir que dans la consommation o
non si c'était une bourse et 722 pôles est en
condition qui n'est pas heureuse si c'est une espèce
de nous tous à une convocation au milieu des îles
aux votes partenaires de la ndrangheta le
lentilles mo paco loch ness
laissez-moi, j'ai de la chance pour le chrome
quelques si les pièces mais je suis vivant
parce que je ne sors pas
à l'intérieur de la maison pensant comme un rex
trompettiste j'essaie de ne pas exister
donc tu ne comprends pas les gens pas moi
Je vois des gens je ne sais pas où j'habite pas
il n'y a rien comme le chef louis
bonaventure
Je suis né dans une famille Ndrangheta qui
ça s'appelle la famille t'en auras une bonne
fortune ceux de mon grand-père était l'un des
grands patrons qu'il commandait
a régné en Calabre
Je ne veux pas que ma famille naisse
combattait déjà 1 querelles de bricolage
Les guerres calabraises sont les mêmes qu'entre
gotha ​​​​était la guerre à mort
du dernier des mâles de l'un des deux
famille
J'ai eu une enfance très traumatisante
fait de violence d'entraînement
dur d'endoctrinement
en fait bébé je ne sais pas si j'ai jamais fait
donc j'ai été élevé comme un
enfant soldat
[La musique]
pouvez-vous nous dire comment il a grandi et
formé comme un enfant poli avec
l'éducation de l'art comme un enfant
pour ensuite tuer déjà enfant
cependant ils font venir les abattoirs qui
ils montrent comment trian tue
baie maudite et le sang va
manger la viande crue qu'ils font
sortir un animal qui tue
certains animaux en goûtent beaucoup
familier avec la mort dans un
famille de grand-mère depuis oui
petit, cependant, coutumier d'avoir
arrêter avec des armes légères
mon père qui rapportait des fusils à la maison
julie game era montable et démontable
les émeutes de retour les montent en peu de temps
possible de le nettoyer c'est un jeu d'époque
fascinant ou pas que j'ai compris
précisément qu'ils étaient des outils de
décès
quand plus tard j'ai réalisé que c'était
vrai que les enfants mâles coincés
avec des armes que je ne comprenais pas qui est le
contrairement aux leurs étaient des armes
mon jouet était de vraies armes et le mien
J'ai commencé à tirer petit oui
commence à tirer en l'air
sûrement je l'aurai tiré dans
une campagne désolée comme un enfant
on parle comme un enfant à partir de
inédit entre 12 13 14 ans
nous sommes allés directement aux endroits
blocs où le mien a été formé
père des mythes qu'ils nous ont appris à
poignée donnée parmi les plus d'armes de ce type
d'art étaient étaient des armes à feu de divers
qu'il a ensuite épargné de la marque qu'ils étaient
les fusils seront également des pistolets automatiques et des mitraillettes
bref, il y avait plusieurs armes
donc une façon unique de le tenir un
les façons de viser sont nombreuses
technique que lentement tu fais tu fais
deux comme s'ils étaient toujours trouvés
c'était fascinant de toute façon tu ne l'as pas
savoir qu'alors les mêmes armes e
vous utiliserez sur les gens alors si un
a fait un enfant qui pourrait avoir des emplacements
sannicandro 16 ans a quelque chose de
du voyage aller
ça grandit ça grandit mais on parle de
une ndrangheta qui relativement
l'exemple est sorti dans la période de
enlèvements qui alors
bloquer les enlèvements
shan sinha danse cette entreprise velox
le design et son soleil di susa di
catwoman gis la drangheta agli
cris spécialistes du riz
stratégie lisse de la télévision
l'organisation sur certains des avantages
que le pire des jeunes la fidh drogue la
drangheta si la ruine lyon sav cla
Caché en Amérique comme jamais là-bas
ndrangheta s'est retrouvé à devenir le
premier importateur de cocaïne en
l'europe regarde alors entre les trois voleurs
gone a le pouvoir et de pouvoir distribuer
n'importe quoi dans tous les coins du monde
c'est pourquoi les signes sont
brésiliens rivière columbia et soliani
Les Boliviens ou les Mexicains préfèrent
ils préfèrent traiter
les dragonistes car en tout cas ils sont beaucoup
ramifié sur tous les continents
le grand âge paie et il y a un taux bas
des collaborateurs de justice
c'est donc un partenaire idéal pour eux plus le
le chiffre d'affaires de la ndrangheta est faible
moins de 53 milliards d'euros pour arriver
à près de 53 milliards d'euros
vous devez ajouter l'épingle du paraguay
celle de la Bosnie et celle de l'Islam
cependant, cela a changé beaucoup de choses
revenu d'argent quand cela est arrivé
tu n'as pas changé tant de choses ont changé
tant de choses et cela apporte encore un
apporte le montant du capital dû
les guerres des dieux sont arrivées
utilisateurs tués tués
c'est-à-dire que je me suis retrouvé dans des contextes de
la guerre donc c'était brenda contre
drangheta ressemble et contre la famille
[La musique]
Je sais que c'est très compliqué pour toi
en parler, mais dans les années 96, il a été forcé
passer aux armes pour s'occuper d'un
situation de meurtre oui vous pouvez
Explique la situation
J'ai parlé des années 90 qui étaient là
cette mission où pourtant il y avait un
partie de l'olive carmi qui menaçait
l'existence même de la nôtre
famille aussi la sécurité physique de
notre famille
alors ils demandent à sa famille de décider à qui
est en action aussi parce que quelques mois
première en août 90
ils ont tué le fils d'un de nos fidèles
puis a quitté la gare où dans
cette action ne peut pas mourir le chef qui
à l'époque
il se proclame chef de la ville de
le double meurtre de crotone s'est produit hier à
crotone il y aurait eu une seconde
personne pour laquelle il est supposé
l'accusation de concours au double
le meurtre dans le rôle était celui de
sentinelle pour donner des informations quand
les gens qui étaient censés mourir étaient sur
l'endroit a plus à faire que l'autosuffisance
parce qu'ils pourraient s'échapper
en fait le commando et les parcs nationaux
rester mort et ne pas savoir à quoi servent les blessures
dis que tu as du sang sur les mains
mais sûr que j'ai du sang sur tes mains tu seras
ça le libère à la vérité ok moi quand je suis
Je suis trouvé dans un meurtre comme
interprète au début j'ai tout fait depuis
manuel avec précision avec un film
avec la formation que j'avais tout
tout dans la tête très lentement
précis, cependant, vous êtes les comptes
je ne les ai pas entendus la situation que cela
il était très bien né donc c'était quatre ans
devenu gérant d'un
la famille apporte le dîner
Je me suis marié avec une femme qui ne
appartenait à ce groupe ethnique et donc
cependant pero lentement lentement moi
donné
ils m'ont donné le genre libre de vivre
différemment et le look vient des pieds
enfants que je décide de ne pas donner
cette éducation, je me trouve souvent un
marcher dans le couloir de la maison
se demandant comment ce serait
l'éducation qui aurait induit proro e
J'ai souvent réalisé que même si
amertume violente
je me préparais pour l'éducation
appartenant à des collections en en parlant
avec ma femme qui était une étrangère certaine
environnements
en effet si je ne l'ai pas dit et donc plus
chaussé elle me dit les deux peines minimales
responsabilité
et aujourd'hui il vit 6 je lui dis à mon père
ce que j'ai conçu je veux
tomber détachement de l'actif de la vie
de l'adhésion, il ne m'a pas dit
rien
après quoi ils se sont organisés en famille
ils ont pensé à supprimer
problème et c'était ce qu'il fallait faire pour moi
dehors
le soir du 18 septembre 2006 où
il me tend une embuscade avec d'autres
en attendant que mon père était là
le pistolet tire ceux qui ont le pistolet et ont
tiré 12 13 ports
et puis j'ai renvoyé le feu j'ai cherché
le mettre en position de ne pas lui donner
toute la silhouette en bref essayant de
rester
d'épaule donc ça donne moins de volume que
je dois me sauver
Je pensais que je l'arrêterais de
le neutraliser en essayant de ne pas le tuer
l'émir a tiré vers les pieds vers le
les jambes l'ont en fait blessé à l'aine
quand tu es ton père devant toi avec
une arme à feu qui est dans votre esprit que vous
te traverse l'esprit quand je me moi
J'attendais cette heure parce que de toute façon un
fret 11 11 et demi j'étais sous la maison pas
Je m'attendais à ce que je n'imaginais pas souffrir
une embuscade mais ils tirent toujours
contre le fils
les balles étaient dirigées vers
voici que la balistique a trouvé
nombreuses balles au niveau des yeux
J'ai juste réussi à survivre
cette papauté
grâce aussi à la formation que j'ai
eu cependant c'est aussi sûr de toute façon j'ai
eu tant de chance ou pour qui c'est
religieux
Dieu m'a regardé mais pourquoi a-t-il
a demandé à ton père de faire ça
parce que dans le granda tu touches quand c'en est un
une telle chose est une infamie un
trahison
c'est au plus proche parent de le laver
comment vivez-vous si l'un des nôtres trahit
humeur je le tue moi-même que je suis le
père s'entraînant comme de l'argent
fils donc d'un sentiment de pouvoir non
après cet épisode je suppose qu'il y a
vous êtes
Je n'en ai jamais parlé parce que c'est arrivé plus tard
cet épisode tu pars tout de suite non
décoller été arrêté pour ça
tentative de meurtre, j'ai alors décidé de
collaborer avec la justice
[La musique]
en février 2007 il collabore avec
justice et il est impensable qu'elle puisse
les mots sortent de ma bouche
à tel point que le jour où j'ai fait le
premier rapport dénonçant certaines choses
à partir de ce jour pendant trois ans et demi non
Je n'ai rien fait d'autre que souhaiter mourir
bien structuré d'une manière et
remis à neuf de manière plus difficile
expliquer
combien de procurations obtenir
travail collaboré j'ai donné le mien
contribution collaborative où tant et où
il y a peu de temps 14 procureurs d'Italie
J'ai contribué un minimum à semble rester
plus de 500 personnes à la diète, j'en ai donné un
cartographie de celui qui l'a draguée
assez important aussi ce que
son organigramme
ou mon témoignage a servi
faire pendre le marché plus que
l'histoire des patrons les plus importants de la
grand-père que le livre dans un grand vol
[La musique]
J'ai créé une véritable entaille dans le mur de
une méta et vulgairement comme la
Faber
luigi bonaventura et molo g série de mini
8 septembre 7 nuits et puis il y a plus de ça
ndrangheta hier sont les ronds du feu
pour s'éliminer a proposé une Italia Fawi
mauvaise direction de la critique à son sujet 34
tangible vous assassiner comme vous vivez
tu es obligé de vivre complètement caché
Ta vie
Je suis obligé de vivre caché non
ils parlent
aujourd'hui les mafias ont plus que le cinéma elles tuent
le repenti
mais bref, que dois-je faire et moi qui là
photo avec la mort moi enfant que je suis
ils ont appris à vivre avec la mort
donc je vis avec la mort ceux
Parfois j'aurais dû mourir
alors disons que je suis endetté
avec la mort
[La musique]